I was saying that my listeners have been
complaining cuz I used to have music at
the opening the podcast and then
honestly I don't know why I stopped
because I changed networks and I was too
lazy honestly to figure out how to get
the song that I was using over here so I
just stopped putting music on and then
people actually have been complaining
like we missed the music so I think I'm
gonna start doing this just make my
guest sing on top of the episode I think
it's I think it's wonderful I think we
shouldn't get some little back-end now
maybe some points on this podcast come
up with it yeah you know I'll make sure
and send you a cut of the zeros of
dollars that I'm making oh yeah what
that by Comedy Central live at Gotham
2009 well thank you guys for being here
excited to have you both what crystal
you're a total surprise so okay let me
introduce my guest I never do I never
really introduced people on the show I
just end up talking and then halfway
through I'm like oh yeah by the way mo
mo Mandel co-creator of comedy knockout
which I heard is doing fantastic on
truTV are you happy very excited yeah
we're finishing season one and maybe
like the end of the month and then the
season 2 starts in like November and I
got I just I can finally announce that I
have my first hour comedy special coming
out on C so shut off then the third
called negative reinforcement
yeah and you've been on Comedy Central
Conan a lot of cable stuff a lot of
cable experience a lot of low paying
cable
in my docket yeah that's right oh yeah
you also hosted wait what was the bar
show that you hosted a barmageddon' we
were host buddies for you noticing that
the first season I was hosting
undercover
I think barmageddon' collectively I
think we got 47 viewers why would you
not get I would rather watch you talk
about sex than me talk about alcohol
yeah but the nice thing is your channel
actually comes with TV you know what I
mean my channel also a lot less men were
jerking off or watching my show I think
I don't know I adjure coughed ooh weird
[ __ ] can you look up those ratings like
well you can look up your how many your
overnight ratings can you look up how
much jerking off was done during this
meal knocking off in their mom's based
on what I don't know because I don't got
a weird stuff like this is so
embarrassing but sometimes oh god I
can't believe I'm gonna say this
sometimes I'll be watching like Criminal
Minds or like Law & Order SVU and like
the criminals like turn me on so I'll
actually like master I cannot watch porn
i watch like crime drama to get all like
just a cry for help please like you're
not the stick by the way nice cubes like
hey tell us about how you molested those
kids she's like mm somebody needs to
take a long hot bath ice cube it's
either what no it's iced tea it's iced
tea nice I always mix up the ices
incidentally I'd like to introduce my
other guys the gorgeous hilarious
actress Krista Allen all my guy friends
by the way are so angry with me that
introduced them to you my guy friends
are the same way with you really yes I
told you yesterday I sent you a picture
I'm like so and so wants to go on a date
no I couldn't believe it I was like he's
actually cured that's so rare for me ya
know I was out him for one another you
should out of I don't I don't want out
him because she's cute though
he's cute we're gonna go meet him for
dinner so he's an actor I have a thing
about he's not but he's an actor
director oh that's fine I don't like I
don't date actors anymore really it's
really nice okay so give me the the
female protective here what is the
difference dating an actor a dating a
director oh my god well psychologically
is that a different beast that you're
really dealing with yes I think so I
mean as an actress I can tell you I have
loads of issues and as an actor I think
those same issues apply there's
narcissism but surely a director's
nurses right I mean that's a person who
is who is telling everyone what to do
yes but on the other side the director
has a little bit more of an alpha thing
I think actors seem to be a little bit
more well they're either super
controlling are just complete [ __ ]
there's no in-between is there if you're
making the other two a directors he is
he is he like when people say make love
I actually get nauseous lately
yeah I don't like calling it that what
if you like [ __ ] yes okay I don't
want to be made love to if you want to
make love to me you should like call
some pretty boy says the young lady who
gets off on sex to them I like I want to
be like mistreated and manhandled in bed
but I mean even if he loves me even if
he loves me I don't want the love to
creep in there anything else can I just
say one thing about dating actors versus
directors is my reason for not wanting
to date actors isn't about their
narcissism because
in Hollywood I feel it's really hard to
find people that aren't yes absolutely I
was just talking about man no but but
you're right but my thing is I don't
like it because they're good acting
because like I dated an actor and I
always believed him when he would psyche
seem into me or act like he wasn't
dating other babies
that's just a dude like but if you've
won Golden Globes for being great at
tricking people into believing you then
it's really hard for just an average
girl like me to realize why you're
acting why they can cry really quickly
yeah that's funny because I was actually
on a date last night we went to a
restaurant and there was like a little
cat on the menu and I just sort of like
I don't know why we took her to a strip
club no no it was actually the last nice
restaurant it was a nice it wasn't it
was it was a cat not a [ __ ] okay a nice
cat it was a wholesome feline and
it was on the menu just for some reason
mr. Berle I kind of get that like just
just I don't know why I hate her the
menu my guys I was like hey you know I
should essentially in that cat when the
owners went to Morocco they they found
this cat wander around in the in the
slums of Morocco and actually took it
they they felt bad for us they they
petted a lot and they took him to their
hotel room I know they end up taking it
back to LA and they use it as the cat
for the thing and she was like oh that's
amazing I'm like no I just made that up
because I just sort of like a car I
don't know why I just like thought it
would be funny just like tell us a good
story and then I was like oh but she was
like oh my god I was so so convincing
like I completely believed it right and
I was like I wonder if she's gonna like
be like yeah you were single bottle eyes
that was the the part of that story for
the punchline that wasn't true just in
case she's watching is that why we does
she follow you on social media do you
allow people to follow you that you date
Wow I don't worry I'm not a sorry I'm
not a Saudi prince I'm not able to tell
people who what they're able to do
information I'm not like that guy I
don't like I wouldn't go out and be like
oh like you'd like how I tweeted I
[ __ ] a 49er you mean the other day I
couldn't stand up about that okay first
of all it was a joke
but also I tweeted like the Rams were
playing the 49ers and I tweeted I live
in LA but I [ __ ] a 49er how do I pick
a team right I just tweeted it to be
funny my mom called me yesterday and she
goes when did you date a 14 all right
I'm mom read the tweet against a day
today was MIT while watching iced tea
described a mall s station but I was
trying to explain to my mom I was like
well we didn't exactly date I mean we
went on a date but we didn't really date
after it was kind she was like I don't
want to hear the address right and then
I deleted the tweet you did yeah she
texted me that tweet before she tweeted
it and said I wanted to tweet this tweet
wait you run a bite just for that
specific way and she's like I this is
and I said that's really funny and then
she had already tweeted it it's not like
it was my approval is sometimes when I
want to tweet something that I shouldn't
or when I want to text a guy that I
shouldn't what I do and a lot of girls
do this I'll send that to like seven or
eight people and be like do you think I
should do this and I wait for just one
person to give me the okay and then I do
know it was Glickman actually I sent it
to like eight people and quickman text
back okay that's really funny yeah I
mean we don't do that although Theo von
comedian friend of all of ours I'm sure
often will send me text back is this a
funny tweet yeah too offensive to tweet
is it like bad I do though I do that -
I've sent you tweets before yeah can I
do this and she's like yes and I'm like
if Kate says yes that's a definite no
detects back and say no this does not
matter
oh nothing about this matters that we
heard everything
my favorite is a Jen serger who's you
know one of my best friends her voice
her her online voice is a lot cleaner
than mine so sometimes show come up with
like a really dirty funny tweet she'll
send it to me go you should tweet this
hilarious and I can't
so she'll send me so it's nice because
sometimes you know people will send me
their dirty tweets and I'm like more
than happy tweet it back to your date
last night so I'm confused about the
menu there's a photo of a cat it was it
was a restaurant there was a cat little
door very recently and I really liked
out done no that's a good that's a good
date I mean you know I'm rich this week
my car's the shop and I'm driving the
Dodge Charger
I dated a guy insurance cook who had a
Dodge Charger how'd that work out well
here's the thing oh my god
so yeah Dodge Charger and he spent like
$30,000 like souping up got a super that
I put rims on it I only have it till the
end of the day he's like you should buy
one of those cars that totally fits for
you it's like a douche bag is that such
a douchey car I mean like I like it do
you think that sushi I mean like its I
love it I feel like I lie it's fun it's
cool but it's definitely the mountain
right no it's the two-door but it feels
it
where's the tooth I got a challenger
yeah yeah but it's on the cus way she
may be my son that drives the Challenger
so but your son but he's 19 I what is he
what when I was only 12 she's like I've
gotta meet this girl this podcast and
within the first 10 minutes I'm like
I've already said too much
I need to start this one over I have a
question I could start think how much do
you care what kind of car guy drives I
don't at all I really don't I don't care
huh I don't think about the kind of car
but I think it was Kate I can't I can't
deal with a guy that drives a really
gross like dirty car like if it's like
it can be the oldest car like shittiest
car in the world but the inside has to
be clean if I get in and there's like
trash to talk I'm filthy my car is
ridiculous I have - everywhere I I don't
know so it's mine but that's different
you're not a guy you're having that
backwards I feel like guys are usually
given the leeway to be a little dirtier
and scummy earth and girls are I just
feel if you pair if you pick someone up
for a date if you were picking a guy up
what did you make sure that your car is
the junk in the trunk you know what I'm
saying have you ever seen the meme of
how it will show a guy's apartment and a
girl's apartment and then a guy's car no
girls car and it's always the girls
apartment is is clean the guys is messy
but the girl's car is messy in the guys
it's guys usually keep their car clean
oh I don't know I think it just I think
it just depends on how busy the guy is
that week right I don't know I don't
know I just feel if they pick you up for
a day and they don't take the time later
right because I date yeah
if he's coming to pick you up on a date
yeah okay as opposed to just you grab me
for a while if it was just the question
was do you care what kind of car drag I
drive and then I was like no I don't
think I do and then it went to the messy
thing and I think I would care if I was
like going on the first date and it was
filthy that would be one of my favorite
like for some reason I categories is
like a very American image it's probably
not just America I'm sure it's
everywhere but it's seeing guys as
usually guys on Friday nights Friday
afternoons around 5:00 washing their
cars at like the car wash you see this
yeah yeah I'll take my car if I have a
date that night I'll go and get it
crossing and see this beautiful moment
of all these guys out there it's almost
always guys washing their cars vacuuming
it because I got dates this would be a
good time for you to do one of your like
man moment on the street bikini walk-up
kind of deals cuz it's a great moment
like everyone and this interview like
how like optimistic are you about that's
so I didn't know that existed
yeah girls at dry bar huh so that'd be
interesting girl going to dry bar and
ask the girls what they have going on
that night and what they think is gonna
happen on the date and do the same thing
at the car wash
look at you I'm a really smart guy very
kind hearted person you're trying to get
dates on the podcast you can do that do
you ever have people I mean I'm sure it
happens to the guys hit you up on social
media or online and ask you out it must
happen to you all the time now they
really don't they don't no not really
oh really interesting they're my
intimidating it or just assume you'll
say no probably I don't know maybe
either way I'm not sure what do they do
what about you like you go you just
assume you're like of course like if
well guys do ask me out on social media
but I think it's because I put out a
vibe of like I'll date homeless people
like I'll give anyone a yeah right I
think you're right about
I don't I don't put any vibe out there I
don't think I'd do it you don't put out
I'll [ __ ] homeless guy back I said
date okay I don't think though despite
the 49er I don't just talk 49ers I date
the home I love this quote I think that
should be your new bio on Twitter I
think you should change it today it's so
sad that that by the way a true like by
the way can I just say can I just say
for my own personal I need to defend
myself
the the 49er is my only ever one-night
stand true one-night stand is it a one
day stand it well on your you're saying
you've had sex with mid love [ __ ] guys
on the first night but once but then on
because one-night stand is generally you
[ __ ] someone the first night and then
you basically never saw him again so are
you saying you [ __ ] you on the first
night and then continue to see them
because that's that's also very
different the 49ers the only guy I ever
[ __ ] on the first night I met them
really yeah really but also Krista your
answer is that we hire yeah no no I
really don't [ __ ] many people no I'm
saying baby you've had more than that I
have not one nightstand I've had in my
entire life I've had two one-night stay
off C in my entire life how often do you
hook up on a first date I don't see I
don't know some make it out know it what
I don't hit I don't kiss until I know
we're gonna be until I feel it like I
don't kiss on a first date really ever
how do you know that how do you know you
have any chemistry until you do some few
or mentally like all of that like just
being able we would never make out no
I'm just saying like oh you know you
know you
when you sometimes do that first kiss
you're coming at you coming really we
don't write about plenty where I thought
we had chemistry and then we do they
kiss I'm like oh we know I can see where
what mo means behind of those guys you
have you ever dated someone like I went
out with a guy we went on like four or
five dates and I liked him and honestly
the nights when we didn't drink I would
kiss him and be like I don't think we
have chemistry and yeah but then finally
when we did hook up because I did hook
up with them and honestly I hooked up
with them as a I think I need to hook up
with him to see and we didn't I never
saw him again and that was it
I know literally it was the worst sex I
ever had and I never talked to him again
and he never taught we both knew it was
like we both knew that it wasn't them
who do you think here's got the worst
sex I've ever had story you yeah why you
say that's so fast just cuz I had the
question I you just seemed like I know
cuz you used to be pretty frigid and
didn't know how to ever had sex right
back in you told me about this I never
said I was for you never had sex and he
got out of the marriage I will say I was
in experience was pretty horrible
I was never well I mean here's the thing
I was always a freak even when I was
married I always wanted to have crazy
sex but he didn't he didn't but the
first guy I dated right out of my
marriage was luckily like real into all
kinds of like crazy [ __ ] so I think I
went from one extreme which was never
really hooking up to the other extreme
which was like hooking up everywhere
like movie theaters and like dressing
room I love I love having sex in public
places I have a thing for that yeah not
in front of people right but but like it
like at the dressing room at a store or
something like that what's your worst I
have no interest in doing that really
yeah it just doesn't I don't know I like
I like public displays evasion like I
like making out but just like I like
anybody could see you know I don't mind
like making out in this but like there's
no the real like tamiya like the I like
the intimacy the privacy of like like
nothing better mean like
hotel room or loud music goin you paid
for the full hour
why is hotel room sex the best it's my
favorite too is it's just like you can
just you know you you know it cuz when
you come up with a shot a girl in your
apartment you know you you have to like
you know I think like okay how many
tells me guys how the clean towels my
god don't want to burn a clean towel on
this cleanup job or do I want to grab
some toilet paper to sort of like do
this like why this [ __ ] grab a towel
[ __ ] wipe it off girl that girl it's
where your laundry is at for that week
is it bad I got one clean towel left
regardless its you know Jennifer Lopez
I've got to think now I don't wanna I
don't want to beat Alice now and you
know it's logically I'm just as is in
your bed and you're gonna grab a dirty
towel because how could you like reach
in the dirty clothes that's what I use
when guys are cool a t-shirt that's way
more worse and Kleenex when guys
respectful when guys are my babies my
boxers off the floors just wipe your
stomach
oh just wiping off my elbow most saying
that that's so insulting but I've done
it and it sounds like you up to when the
guys are at my house I'll be like just
grab a t-shirt out of the hamper like I
really tell guys do that maybe because
it's my dirty but it's about to get
dirty anyway well that's that's where
the talent do you like do I want to burn
a perfectly clean towel here I agree
it's not respect or like is she worth
this or that it's purely like your house
so after sex she's gonna take a shower
boom another towel gone you know I mean
you can't have her use your wet towel so
you already got another towel gone then
you clean up with another towel
I only have my four towels listen go to
the 99-cent store
I just bought like a six pack $4.99 Wow
Wow yeah great idea Wow at the 99-cent
store is six for a dollar you've been on
any really awful just god-awful dates
that you remember that I don't really
date I've always in relationships I know
that sounds so weird but if I see if I'm
with somebody I'll generally go on a
date with that person knowing that we
are going to be in a relationship even
know I don't know jerking off I yeah
that's true yeah like when I jerk off
that's it that's it I don't go on a lot
of dates I don't date I've never been on
a tender thing or I've never been on in
no dating ups I've never done that yeah
I just
go on tinder like I mean celebrity guys
go on tinder like I match with Terrell
Owens on tinder right yeah not even Ryan
no that was before Ryan came out that's
what I was gonna ask would you go on
riah have you been on there I don't know
I don't know I think I would you know
what I get it but I think I would rather
kind of meet somebody the old-fashioned
way and like a friend says this or that
or whatever I feel like there's like
this really weird lack of connection
that's going on and then it's all about
the looks and it's all about that I
don't know I'm not a big look person I
really like the yeah I don't know I
myself as a sapiosexual yeah I would say
miss sapiosexual is that term you know
what that means right
no sapiosexual means you're aroused by
intellect yeah it's a real term real
term but it's all over the oh yeah now
I'm a sapiosexual was I mean my last
boyfriend look like a troll he was
really good at engineering it was a
whole spectrum of things of course but
that is like a term that's used that's
not a real thing because look I would
challenge any guy but you sit in a chair
and have a girl just like read science
to him and it's almost exclusively women
who say that I don't know I don't know
what guys post online I don't know
that's weird though Wow
like girls that are only into guys that
are like super smart I mean I love smart
guys I love nerdy guys I love smart guys
I love that's my thing like sciency guys
I do like all of that stuff I like them
to be smart but not as smart as me
because I want to be able to outsmart
them so [ __ ] yes I need them to read
at a first grade level
do you think I'm a lot smarter than I am
no you're very smart I mean you're about
Martin industrious person and I'm not
kidding I mean like you found ways to do
like ways that you things have you done
in your career marketing so thank you
you definitely one thing I will say
about you though is I always hear you
talk about dating athletes and dating
you know you're doing a porn star for a
while right it's not use the word star
but I was gonna at least he was a star
dick number three No thank you for I'm I
waited barmageddon' one episode we're in
a bar and they were like oh that that
waitress is a porn star and I was like
all right and I like looked rapping and
first of all she was her she was not she
needs some work like a star she just she
had like this really annoying voice and
then the way she her voice is not and
then the way she had sex was also in
that voice it was just like oh god she's
not gonna be the star it's like if you
saw someone like I think this is not
gonna I mean I watch it a little bit
online for a second I love Ariana Rousey
it was not good really yeah huh yeah as
a fan so you didn't try it you didn't
try to know I'm very turned off by that
I worry about this one we took our trip
to San Diego to copy the idea of someone
doing porn is totally turn-off to me it
is
you wouldn't even hit it one time know
what scary scary thing but just all the
experience scares me I'm like if I break
a condom with a girl who's had sex one
time in her life I'm like well just got
AIDS and Zika I mean like so like watch
her get [ __ ] by 87 different guys on
line I would never freaked out and I
just judge it morally at all for me I'm
just so neurotic yeah that I think it
would just it would be hard for me
ya know well to be honest with you but
it definitely wasn't like my plan or
something I thought was a good idea I
mean when I met him I literally was like
I can't do it I'm not doing it I told
all my friends I wasn't gonna do it but
then slowly but surely leash the beast
well I got dignity
I mean that's the other thing like if I
had sex with a porn star would she be
like an incredible in bed in a way that
I'd never imagined problem yeah I mean
like but morally I have zero judgment
about I just know myself it would be
very hard for me to I couldn't do it if
I was into or had feelings for somebody
mature knowing like how was your day at
work honey
don't tell me that's the thing is that I
think that in my mind I really like
convinced I almost convinced myself that
that's not what he does cuz I would
never watch I I didn't like I had a
muted on Twitter like I did everything I
could to avoid that topic so in my mind
I'm not like scratch marks and stuff did
you ever sex scratch marks or hickeys on
him
teeth marks on his balls I know in a
weird way yeah no I'm serious because
actually I think it kind of helped me
though understand how much men separate
like sex from emotion in a way yeah I
know it sounds weird but like I kind of
came out of it like less jealous like I
kind I don't know I don't know how to
yeah I think that's PTSD but still
traumatized yeah I don't know like it's
so hard to like I was trying to describe
this to him the other day like it was
like about how as a guy like wow you
know I mean genius I'm wrong and and I'm
totally not saying that it's not wrong
when you hear like in movies guys say
did someone do a girl like it didn't
mean anything it didn't he's like as a
guy you're like no it didn't like you
know right it actually didn't not to say
team is not wrong and you should
definitely not cheat but you know
psychologically it didn't like I said
I've done it and it's like didn't yeah
aside from the guilt you're gonna get
caught it's like it doesn't affect any
of the emotion I literally go about your
day and like maybe it pops in your head
and then you're just like well I mean
[ __ ] I mean
I had to do that thing I mean that's
like it when I was younger and and I
would like sort of do those things but I
wouldn't say it really affected like it
had nothing to do with other than coming
like it with other than but we brought
up the conversation because I was in I
think a lot of women as they get older
in particular can separate sexes
remotion I agree I think it gets easier
I think that it's all about for me at
least it's chemistry if I have crazy
chemistry with a guy like the porn guy's
a great example yeah I don't think the
sex was incredible cause he's a porn guy
I honestly just think we happen to have
amazing chemistry and that chemistry if
you have amazing chemistry in bed
usually you also have amazing chemistry
like mo you and I have great chemistry
like as friends our conversation flows
we do yeah it's just we don't hang out a
lot we're not like the closest friends I
would like to be closer and we do have
that yeah but that's what I mean so it's
like let's say you and I [ __ ] sure
pretty good it would probably be great
and probably I would catch feelings real
quick because we have chemistry whereas
like I could have I had sex with a guy
not that long ago who was honestly
probably the best sex I ever had in
terms of like technically he was amazing
like but I didn't feel anything for him
because I didn't have that kind of
hectic right what is the technical I
mean like he got me off so many times
and like he just he was yeah and like
lots of positions and he was aggressive
and he said the right he did if I wrote
on paper what I wanted a guy he did it
all he hit every track that she weren't
connected to him right and I haven't
since we hooked up I haven't like hit
him up to hook up and how long ago was
that it was about a month ago that's
because you're still yeah hung up on
somebody else yeah I don't think that's
why no I just think I'm not because why
are you guys talking in code it's your
[ __ ] pod
God you have details here like away why
did isn't this your mom talk about
dating and fails I what do you because
no here's the thing is that like I still
kind of have feelings for someone that I
was seeing but we're not seeing each
other anymore and so she's saying and a
lot of my friends will say this that
like the reason I'm not feeling it with
the other guy is because I saw but in my
but in my experience usually when I'm
able to kick old feelings is the minute
someone new comes I get it I don't know
I don't know yeah I don't know either
but it I know what you're saying but
don't you think that chemistry is what
makes you feel something yeah I
definitely think chemistry is yeah it's
not just technique it's not like it's
really great in bed I'm certainly not
technique and for me it's like so much
of it it's like is that person like
physically in the moment you know I mean
like I remember I was with someone one
time anyway and she called me poppy huh
and I was like okay was she that's
someone you saw have sex in a way that
and so now you're not even like here
you're like doing like a I can't care if
you're trying something out like I'm not
the kind of person you would call that
yeah did you like that you like no that
was weird
a lot of girls say daddy like I know
it's like even in text I've been hey
daddy
and I just always think it's creepy but
I know a lot of guys that like it oh
yeah really yeah I meet a lot of those
really yeah I do it's maybe it's the
voice I don't know I don't know you know
what's your type Krista what do you like
my type
I like funny like I need I need funny I
need smart I need nerdy I like you know
those guys want you to call them daddy
I think Matt kirshen yeah can you call
me daddy love no no there's lady
not all of them look here's my thing I
like those guys but I generally pick the
guys that are really controlling in a
lot of ways or very domineering or very
god complex II kind of guys and I like
to take care of that you know
to take your hair like I can fix you oh
my god you must have had such a terrible
childhood for you to be like this let me
give you all my love yeah and I will
save you forever and it never works we
have that in common
I think that's a I think that's a a show
business girls I think girls that are
actresses and comedians and girls that
love to be in the spotlight a lot of us
have that same because every girl I have
on this podcast who's a comic has that
same thing of loving damage guys that
they have to fix well and but it goes on
the reverse too cuz they're loving us
right are we just like the same
absolutely I don't know I said I
definitely used to be super attractive
women who were like damaged and then
after a while I just feel like well [ __ ]
the problem is then you like spend your
whole life dealing with these same
issues all the time and it's like
exhausting like I know I'm too [ __ ] up
to date someone normal like when I'm
dating a girl who's normal and like if
we have a ton of fun I'm like eventually
you're gonna realize like I'm not I'm
not built like you are and I'm gonna
like I'm more [ __ ] up than you are
like you have an easier time with life
and I just don't separate about stuff
and they just
normal their school teachers and nurses
that regular jobs like my sense of self
gets rocked on a daily basis I like try
to figure out what I am
it's like every day is to be picking up
the pieces and like going to be like
well watching narcos like wasn't it was
okay today I didn't I didn't like really
like it lose it for no [ __ ] reason I
like that there's like yoga and it is so
if you're like that you know someone who
doesn't kenderson that it was never
gonna get you on the other hand I don't
want to be with a woman who I only
really the biggest connection is us
relating to being [ __ ] up like that
because then you two spend each other
licking each other's wounds and it's
easy to I think think that love is
mutual repairing but that's not that's
not what love is
mmm-hmm yeah I guess I mean it would be
nice if you could say hey here's my [ __ ]
you take care of that I'll take care of
yours oh it's a beautiful symbiotic
Union but that's exactly the opposite
you do
the opposite of what you should do is
ask someone else to take care of your
[ __ ] because no it's a bleona I mean
like I've relationships because of that
because you're like you know here's it
like because I was in a way for a long
[ __ ] time yeah and the most
fascinating thing for me about being out
of that relationship was I felt so much
of the same problems that I felt inside
continued after that rage if that I had
just blamed on her and it's just like
you know just the general frustration
and depression and sort of boredom and
not really inspired by my life feeling
socially just very like board and
unenthusiastic and I was kinda like at
some of them in this relationship and in
the end I don't want to go out because
I'm a girl and Jenny and she's not and
that's why I'm not doing more comedy cuz
I'm doing this and then we broke up I
was like I feel exactly the same [ __ ]
way like after I went through the highs
and lows of it I'm like my life is still
those sort of issues remain so it's all
me and yeah I said the same thing to me
that so much that she used to blame me
for she realizes it's her own stole you
do hit a point where it's like and I've
been really working out like the last
year I've been really working on just
being happy alone and knowing like I
mean I granted I've been dating people
but I'm finally at a point where it's
like if there's no guy in my life it's
fine because I'm so obsessed with my
career and like fitness and like girl
friendships and like other things I have
going on and then you become more
attractive to the opposite sex when you
start to be someone with your [ __ ]
together a little bit yeah but then
every time I get my [ __ ] together
I think I'm a self-sabotage or because
every time I get my [ __ ] together and I
feel really amazing instead of going for
like that's super sweet guy that'll take
me on like dates the little door and
like text me how was your show I go for
the guy that's like an [ __ ]
until it starts to crumble a little and
then I have to kick him out and ever do
the work of starting over why are you
tired don't you get tired of not
building like I feel like one thing I
like about an adult so much mortis it's
just understanding what like I feel like
I understand what I want and a woman so
much now that it's almost to the point
where it's harder to date because I can
tell right off the top like oh this will
dis this isn't right
like I'm so beyond I feel like that
thing of like
this [ __ ] magic is this is gonna last
cuz it never does there's not even a
[ __ ] it up it's like that passionate
[ __ ] crazy thing it's never last
don't quick that's are like a week now
yeah but those are things these are all
things that is from the beginning of
your first love these are like stories
that have been implanted and stuck into
your subconscious and other stuff so
everything that I'm hearing when I
listen to it yeah I go into like that
Law of Attraction thing where everything
that you believe is what your life is
gonna be it's you think you're a
self-sabotage er that's what you're
gonna be if you believe that with all
your heart that's what you're gonna I
take it back that's right sounds like
chris has got a touch of the Scientology
no she's right love attraction though I
think you're right because like
career-wise that [ __ ] works for me I
just think something's gonna happen and
eventually I'm like I think I'm gonna
get a TV show I'm gonna get a TV show
I'm gonna get it and then you get a TV
show like I do believe that so you're
right if you apply that just don't
believe it say I am a self definitely a
self lift her up or this morning like
seven times yeah I like it
yeah but isn't that like the key to
everything is just the way that we think
wait what happens I'm on a cleanse rooms
I'm on a sex cleanse I'm trying not to
have I've had sex and okay I think it's
been about um maybe almost a month you
know it's so funny why are you doing
that I don't want before it's not on
purpose no exactly it's just because I'm
trying to stop having sex with one
person okay and I'm trying to not here's
the thing so this gets to how you fall
for [ __ ] because you're asking like
why aren't you tired because what I've
realized is I believe everything guys
I'm very like I'm the same I don't lie
and I'm like very honest so when I start
dating a guy everything they say at the
beginning and how sweet they are and all
that stuff I believe it and I end up
hooking up with them too quick that's
like for instance how I caught feelings
for the
guy like at the beginning he said
everything right and I was like he's
maybe he's not just a porn guy like he's
actually like sweet and he wants like a
relationship and so the point is I've
been hooking up too quick and then I
catch the feelings and then I end up
getting hurt when I find out it was all
[ __ ] because they really just wanted
to hook up with me cuz they see me as
like a trophy or whatever so now my new
thing is trying to actually get to know
guys really well and make sure they're
not full of [ __ ] before I [ __ ] them
especially as like a woman isn't there
there's scientific evidence that like if
you have sex with a guy your body emits
some sort of like weird yeah something
that makes you like really to the guy
it's actually not even sexual to me
cuddling it's cuddling you could
literally never [ __ ] and you could just
cut all and the same [ __ ] happens that's
why I always say it's not even this it's
like your body like yeah some sort of
weird physiological it happens to men
too like the same chemical release
happens to men it's like I think
oxytocin or something it's releasing
your brain also but I don't understand
why guys don't get that same feeling of
like addiction to the girl that we cuz
we get actually physically addicted
right to the man I think the
testosterone cancels it out no I feel
like I'm practically what cat meow you
have a lot of female comics have this
kind of thing you know it's a there's
like a do dish quality out of them no no
I mean there's a lot of very very sexy
very beautiful female comedians in LA
and I feel like a lot of them are like
just like this [ __ ] like bro II sort
of quality and then not just in regard
to like sex and stuff it's like there's
like this energy and maybe I don't know
it's interesting it's true it's true
are you got I agree yeah I don't know
why that is that we have well then when
they're in their 40s they all become
lesbians and hoes talk so much thanks so
much I don't
I'm excited I hope you have thank you
I'd be fine we know you're coming out
yes you can I just I don't think that
it's that all the female comics have
that but I think is the ones that
actually end up making it have to have
it because it's such a bro like industry
like to hang around with all you guys
all the time and not end up killing
yourself cuz you guys are not like you
guys start talking guys like we're dudes
and then you start like making like like
making fun of us the way you make fun of
each other like you forget that we're
chicks and then we start to forget that
we're chicks and then before you know it
everybody just we're all just bros in it
together that's what I really believe
bro soup right I want to bring up
another topic before this this is going
so fast but I have recently had
conversations with three guy friends
different friends who broke up with
their girls and all three of them in the
explaining to me why it happened
happened to bring up as one of their
points I would always buy her lingerie
and she'd never wear it like it was kind
of a throwaway thing all of them had a
list of reasons but I thought it was
funny that all three of them mentioned
buying a girl lingerie and she never
wore it in the reasons for the break-up
so I'm just worried 'us yeah because in
my head I was like holy [ __ ] like I
didn't realize guys put so much stake in
lingerie but all these guys are
mentioning launch I want to know what
you guys think about lingerie and
relationships just in general
lingerie relationships great I think
they might be mad because if they didn't
wear it for them she's wearing it for
someone else and now he hates her so he
just added it later what do you think
that is a very dark thought yeah anytime
you buy someone lingerie she's gonna be
ultimately wearing it for the next guy
she's [ __ ] I mean that it like and
then it's also dark it's also dark at
some of the lingerie that I mean a girl
that I maybe I'm dating that has that I
like like I wonder what you got right I
mean I've had guys my guys are weaned
each other's bodies in this mortal coil
I means true you wash it sometimes you
might owe it's not
you used it to wipe the lash no but I
mean I I'm curious cuz like my friend
was like so you know I would always I
would buy her lingerie and she never
wear it and like I was thinking to
myself like I've bought lingerie for
guys and shown up at their house wearing
it and they don't even mention it you
know they don't say anything about it so
then in my mind I'm like do they even
care or they just take it off but then
it seems like it always comes up that
guys want girls to wear it so I was just
curious how important it is to you as a
man not at all in terms of like if she
wears if I buy her lingerie and I know
she doesn't wear it a lot I don't unless
like I mean like some guys are like no
kinky about they really care what
somebody's wear like me it's like no
matter what lingerie a woman has on like
I want to get her naked like pretty much
as fast possible like it's not yeah
there's like fetish things like a fetish
dress like wanted everything to like be
dressy and there was stuff and let's put
dress like there was a whole thing I
don't know okay when a girl keeps her
shoes on I think that's yeah like try
really it's like try her yeah it's kind
of like that's so funny cuz I hooked up
with a guy who was like I'm really only
into it if you wear heels that's so
weird
it's fetishy right I think that I think
lingerie is pretty and it's awesome and
it says Lala right like that issues are
naturally like despite the nature of
fetishes an intimate yeah it really I
like it well because you like because
I'm afraid of I think anytime someone
like this focus that it's like okay if a
girl gets really turned on because I
find a lot of times women or maybe women
I keep on the shoes because they think
you're that's what I want or so I've
heard it's to keep your shoes on before
I mean I've had both I mean to me it's
like it's I could take or leave it but
it's a little bit of a turn-on sometimes
if I feel like she's doing it she's
doing it cuz like that to her is the
thrill cuz I don't then it to me it's a
turn because like I want to be the
sexual thrill for you I don't want that
any kind of fetishes like they're
getting off on something that's not you
but if it's you not but see I don't know
is to let that you know I don't think
it's
you know I don't think it's true because
I'll tell you cuz like when I'm home
alone getting off you know I use toys
right sure but I'm Way more turned on
when a guy that I'm into it uses the
same toy at me
that's completely different how is it
different because a [ __ ] toy like a
vibrator is a scientifically engineered
thing to help with your orgasm so it's
like sure it's more attractive when
someone is touching you and if they're
touching you with something that is
amazing for that then of course but
that's not a fetish a fetish with music
I just came you didn't see me blink it
was it was there was if there was a
blink Chris I used to be in prison for
years and you had to come silently learn
how to come like a ninja no but I mean
like a fetish would be is if the guy is
holding the [ __ ] vibrator and that's
around but if he's touching you with it
that it's different that's true I can
see what you're saying about the shoes I
don't know though but like being
handcuffed being tied up that kind of
stuff that's all fetish play but that's
really hard to me you think that's
because there's I don't know I just I
personally just do you like doing the
tying up to the guy you okay I like both
but like the other side more yeah I do
like the other side more yeah but I
don't really like both right I really do
but I'm definitely a little more
submissive you hope yeah yeah me too for
sure but I think you have like the I
think there's something about the
fetishy thing for sure it's fun and it's
exciting but it does take the intimacy
away I like it's not I mean like I'm
wearing like a Wonder Woman outfit knows
like oh this is really [ __ ] hot I
maybe I can get into this right or like
sometimes girl wear shoes sure it is it
is sexy but to me it's like interesting
if you say like guys like I need you to
wear shoes like then it's like [ __ ]
crazy to me like then it's like like you
know like a lot times girls can you know
they like even when like people tell you
how to it's I don't know I mean everyone
gets off in their own way you know so
I don't know to me it's a physical stuff
if you want someone to hold you and
choke you I get that like if you want
somebody to like [ __ ] you know some
girls like to be spanked it isn't that
or if you want to grow if I can scratch
you it whatever it is like that's more
physically there's something there but
if it's like if you want you [ __ ]
away wear that hat it's kind of like
okay yeah I can see that like I mean
like I host a show about weird fetishes
and like there are people that like can
only get off if they're like balloons
involved like stuff like that like I
guess I can see what you mean yeah I
mean but it happens but then there's
part of me that's like in some ways to
be honest just I I kind of feel like
because I'm a little reserved for a
while with a new guy sometimes until I
really trust them enough to let them see
like you're crazy my dark side yeah so
actually in some ways like I think I
wouldn't tie a guy up or blindfold a guy
unless I was really kind of intimate
with that guy so then there's some
actually like more level of intimacy I
mean I guess it can go in either way
right I don't know what you think at
home like adorable skank in the world
yeah people will like blow up balloons
and then like titty [ __ ] girls with it's
a thing I guess you know that this guy
told me like he got his first erection
at the circus that he remembered and so
everybody with erections yeah that's how
these fetishes a lot of them form is cuz
something like that happens at a young
age they say they say that's what I'm
learning I see I've learned so much from
hosting on Playboy TV I feel grateful
that's amazing yeah I feel like this I
feel like we covered so much today I
really did mo do I know Krista you said
you don't really date much do you have
an
full date fail that you want to share
before we go your worst date story can
remember ok well the one time I did
JDate J swipe Jewish dating swipe app I
had a girl show up it was almost like a
sketch about what it would be like and I
hate to say this cause like if she's
happy but anyway she showed up and she
was the most jewy person I'd ever it was
like Kyle's mom from South Park showing
up she was like wow it was like within
like 30 minutes I was just like um but
this is like a [ __ ] sketch I'm like
what it would be like to be a Jewish
datings like she might as well have been
like you want a place with dreidel well
the drinks come to my Jewish listen it
is terrible and I did the worst slide
together I was like I gotta go yeah I'm
like I gotta get to the comics like
already I was like why you know cuz I
gotta get to the improv and I realize
that he's [ __ ] up my own line I was
like all right I'll see you later she
was like alright well I'm gonna have a
drink more power to girls together like
what kind of like cut a date short but
it was just like hearing like I felt
like my mom was like big tits and she
was showing those up she knew that was
restraint that was reception area that
was it but did you know did you see her
before I've seen some photos but they
weren't I didn't come with a vocal boys
can [ __ ] some [ __ ] I really can't
yeah that scares me because I kind of
sound like a man I don't know a guy told
me the other day that my voice could
turn a man gay I'm just thinking about
dicks right now thank you so much for
doing this do you have anything mo you
should plug your comedy knockout on
truTV airs every Monday and Wednesday at
11:00
my show that I created and my special
negative reinforcement comes I don't see
so November 3rd so rad Christina Polly
anything I don't really have anything to
plug myself I go see Moe do his stuff
you can follow me at Krista Allen X Oh
follows her and we're shooting a
hilarious sketch this week just gonna be
a dope course I'm writing comedy right
now I'm doing that and doing all this
next time I come on I'll have something
to promote your amazing follow her
follow at mo mandel you know follow me
@kq funny I love you guys thanks for
listening